كانت هذه هي طريقه الالتفاف على العقوبات
لكن كيف ردت روسيا على العقوبات ذاتها
راويه طبعا نددت روسيا نددت بشده
بالعقوبات الغربيه على صادراتها من التقاء
وبخاصه ملف تسعير نفطها في الاسواق فكما
نعلم مشاهدينا الصادرات الطاقه هي عصب
الاقتصاد الروسي بوتن اختار الرده بالمثل
هيتعلنا حضره صادرات النفط للدول التي
فرضت سقف اسعار على المنتجات البتروليه
الروسيه هذا يعني بان روسيا مطالبه الان
بمواصله البحث عن اسواق بديله للبيع نفطها
بسعر الذي يناسبها وبكميه جيده وهو ما
كانت قد نجحت في تحقيقه من قبل حيث غيرت
الوجه صوب اسواق اسيويه وافريقيه ومن
امريكا اللاتينيه لكن حينها لم تكن قد
صدرت بعض عقوبه سقف السعر على ايه حال فان
هذه العقوبات قد
على اصحابها فاذا لم تتمكن روسيا من
العثور على عدد كاف من المشترين والترت في
النهايه الى خفض الانتاج فقد يؤدي ذلك الى
استنزاف المخزون العالمي ما قد يرفع
الاسعار مره اخرى هناك اشكال يطرح ايضا
داخل المعسكر الغربي وتحديدا اوروبا
المضطر الان الى البحث بشكل كلي عن
امدادات بديله ومناسبه ايضا وفي حال فشلت
في ذلك فان العقوبات قد تتسبب في رفع
التكاليف تكاليف استيراد النفط بالنسبه
لاوروبا الاكثر من ذلك هو ان بعض الاطراف
قد تستفيد من هذا الوضع حيث ستكون قادره
على شراء النفط الروسي باسعار منخفضه ثم
بيعه مكررا الى المشترين في الاتحاد
الاوروبي بسعر اعلى بكثير الكلام هنا
تحديدا ينصب ويتوجه الى الصين اذا سيظل
الغرب يحاول وستظل روسيا تحاول على هل مع
الجيران الاقرب وهذا ما يعكسه كلام وزير
الخارجيه الباكستانيه الزائر لموسكو هذه
الايام
ودوليا حتى بين القوه العظمى نحن نقدر
علاقتنا مع روسيا ولا نرى انها مستاءه من
التطورات في العلاقات الدوليه كما نقدر
بشكل متساوي علاقاتنا مع الولايات المتحده
واوروبا ستظل باكستان على الدوام صوتا
مؤيدا للسلام والحوار والدبلوماسيه في
المجتمع الدولي
في البلاد بعد سلسله العقوبات التي فرضت
على موسكو وخسارتها لاسواقهم مبيعات ضخمه
لكن ذلك لم يمنع موسكو من بيع الذهب
الاسود بما في ذلك عن طريق البحر الى
اسواق المدينه لتبدا روسيا بيتوجيه
صادراتها من النفط والغاز الى اسواق جديده
من الدول الاسيويه منها الصين والهند
وتركيا وباكستان
باسعار الاشخاص صعوبات تقنيه ستواجه روسيا
ايضا من اجل عاده توجيه صادراتها من
الطاقه ستحتاج روسيا على سبيل المثال الى
توسيع خط انابيب قوه ايبيريا الذي يذهب
الى الصين من اجل زياده ضخ الغاز اليها